Holotalk and Profiles in Holography is brought to you through the generous support of the International Holography Fund.
For more information, visit their website at holographyfund.org.
It's equally Martin Richardson.
Hi, speaking.
How are you?
This is Frank Defratus.
Hiya, Frank.
Uh of course you know, this is the Holotalk Show.
Yep.
Which I'm not sure if you're aware of it or not, but I bring holographers on and interview them and have been doing that for a number of years.
I've been following your work for some time now, Frank.
Well, thank you.
Well, thank you very much.
Absolutely.
It's not my first calling in life, but I decided to do it and uh anyway, it's good to have you on, and I know everyone's going to love hearing about you, but there's so many things to cover with Martin Richardson that uh I don't even know where to start, but I guess maybe we could start with you giving a little bit of your early history on how you got started with holography, and then we can move on to some of your projects and your books and your presentations and the conferences that you've been involved with and just take it from there.
But what about your early work?
Wha how did you get started with holography in the first place?
Um I guess um like many people, um, visiting the Science Museum in London was the first contact I had with um with the Dennis Gabor hologram.
Okay.
The uh amazing meter square cabor hologram that I think was created by uh Nick Phillips, I'm not sure.
That was the uh laser transmission hologram of him behind the desk, is that correct?
Yes, that's the one.
Um so that was my initial, you know, uh contact with philography as a kid.
And I guess it it sort of stuck with me from there.
It wasn't until I went to art school and in the early sort of seventies, mid seventies, I met a guy called Paul Wharton, who was working with Reb R Rebecca I think it's Rebecca Rebecca Booth or Roberta Booth.
Okay, yes.
Um at uh Goldsmith's University, and that was about 1980.
I believe it's Roberta Booth.
Roberta Booth, after Roberta Booth and Rebecca Deem.
Yes, indeed.
Two two great ladies of philography.
Yes.
Um I went out an evening course with uh Paul Warton and made my first tiny hologram, which was uh very difficult to see.
It was like looking into a muddy puddle.
And uh it was a piece of magic for me.
And uh, you know, I began to read more about the way holography was being developed by people like um Margaret Benyon and uh Bill Moltini in the States.
And the more I heard about these things, the more my interest grew, and uh really it's been uh a lifelong experience ever since.
Now I had a chance to see a few of your pieces on the web in the Jonathan Ross collection.
Right.
And I understand you have a website of your own, which is updated regularly, so I'll include a link to that.
Thanks.
Uh but I believe I may have s had a chance to see one of your works personally.
You may have been in an exhibit in the Museum of Philography, it was called holography redefined or something like that.
Yeah.
Yes, indeed.
Now you did you specialize in portraiture work?
Because I noticed a number of portraits that were in different collections.
Um it wasn't until I basically finished my master's degree at the Royal College of Art that I began to specialise in in portraiture.
Was that a holography degree that you uh obtained there, the masters?
Uh well when I began at the Royal College it was nineteen eighty two and there was already a sand table established by somebody you may have heard of, uh Jeff Blythe.
Oh, absolutely.
Uh an amazing chemist, he's working in Cambridge University at the moment.
And in fact I'm gonna be working on a project in the near future with Jeff recording uh the Harrison Clocks from the Greenwich Observatory in London.
Hmm on a project to do with longitude.
Um but uh when I enrolled at the Royal College we were working on the sand table and uh completed my master's in uh holography there in nineteen eighty four.
And Andy Pepper was my external um supervisor for that.
So another name there, Andy Pepper.
Oh yes, absolutely.
Uh but the Royal College didn't get their first later until I graduated.
And then I came back the following year and completed the PhD, which uh gave me the opportunity to start working with pulse lasers and uh met people like uh Odwina Raw who'd open up the Richmond holographic studios.
Wow, what great work came out of there.
Incredible stuff, it was so groundbreaking.
You know, I remember seeing the first pulse holograms that they produced for John Webster of uh Boy George.
Hmm.
Oh, yes, I remember that.
I mean I mean these were fifty by sixty acromat uh reflection pieces and they were mind blowing.
Mm-hmm.
So lots of grammar was being broken there.
And I suppose at the same time people like um Eve Richer was developing exhibitions such as uh Light Dimensions and uh that really sort of brought my work to the f you know uh sort of public awareness.
Yeah.
And uh there was a it was a good time for holography.
Did I noticed one of uh one of your pieces was a pulse reduction.
Did that come out of RCA as well?
Yes it did.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Did see I have one from uh Jonathan Cope.
Oh yeah.
And uh you don't see very many of them.
I think Fred Unterseer had actually did the only one that I saw many years ago that was on display here in the US.
Right.
Yeah.
How did you get involved with so many of the stars?
Celebrity type of uh holographic portraiture.
How does someone even uh get into that realm?
Do you go over to David Bowie's house and have breakfast or something or what?
Yeah.
You do.
Fantastic.
He he collects holograms.
No kidding.
Um one of the first he collected was by um Peter and Anna Marie Nicholson.
Oh, no kidding, yes.
I think they sh they shot it um a post hologram of one of the stage sets he was involved in designing for the Glass Spider Tour.
Mm-hmm.
And this was uh fifty by sixty piece, and uh that was one of his first of the collection.
Wow.
So he's very supportive of the field of holography, huh?
He speaks very highly of it.
David's one of these um, you know, very intelligent people that likes to keep a finger on anything that's new, any new developments in technology.
As is uh evident from his website.
Um but I first met him when I visited an exhibition he was having in London.
And uh it was one of those occasions where um, you know, he's a sort of a demigod and nobody really wanted to embarrass themselves by talking to him.
And I took a deep breath, walked over to him and started to talk about holography, and uh he said to me, Well, would you like to design an album cover?
And that's something I did for his uh ours album, which was released in nineteen ninety nine.
And went to New York, we struck up a friendship and uh I made a f uh small uh film of him, shot with the stereo rail system from what was then applied holographics.
It was uh a camera designed by um Craig Newswanger.
And uh that that footage has since been uh transit into a reflection uh digital hologram by Giola.
Oh David Ratcliffe.
So that was we gave him a copy for his six-year birthday and he was really pleased with that.
Sixty years old, isn't it something?
Incredible.
Yeah, here we go.
This is it.
Enjoy it while we got it, man, because time is ticking down.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well, I'm not I'm not real familiar with uh David's music that much.
But uh I know he's known throughout the world and it's very nice that he's been supportive with holography and uh found it uh fascinating enough to support it.
So um I don't know where he would be in the future with it.
I d is it just like a once and done type of uh crush or something or is it an ongoing interest that he still has to this day?
Um I don't think it is.
I think um the door's still open there.
There's there's as we know there's lots of new things happening with panchromatic emulsions and full color.
Yeah.
And you know, the amazing work that Mike Kluke and Craig Newsmanger are uh working on at Zebra at the moment.
Mm-hmm.
Which is is really um awe inspiring and it's the type of thing that I'm sure Bowie would be receptive to.
Um it's it's just you know, it's a c question of time and and getting the right images uh the the right window of opportunity to to show to somebody like David Bowie or one of the the other celebrities I've been, you know, fortunate enough to work with and just uh you know, if the timing's right then and they can see an opportunity then certainly they'll they'll use it to you know promote holography to to where it should be among the the super media.
Now you have a book as well.
Prime Illusion.
What's the other book besides Prime Illusion?
The the first book was was called Space Bomb.
Space Bomb.
Huh.
Uh you know, I I I play with words and uh Yes.
Uh like to be as creative with uh you know the stuff I put out as possible and I I thought of the hologram as being a sort of a you know a capsule of space and if the image is dynamic enough, it's a sort of a bomb, so space bomb.
Oh, absolutely.
Um and it it really documents uh my first twenty years involvement with the media.
Uh from the early sculpture right through to uh the more you know, advanced uh holographic pulse butcher.
So Space Bomb was the first, and the second was the prime illusion, which was the more I suppose more I get more of an academic attempt to ask the bigger questions, such as, you know, where are we going with holography?
What does it mean?
Um where do where where does it sit philosophically uh within society now?
How is society's being transformed by um the onslaught of digital media?
Mm-hmm.
How do you feel about that about the digital technologies moving into holography?
Do you feel that that's taking some of the craftsperson uh ship away from the field?
Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
Um I'm I'm I'm really excited by the uh convergence of uh digital technology and holography.
I think it's gonna open up new pathways, it's going to uh broaden the the the entrance uh point for young people coming into the field.
And um you know, holography's gone through this sort of evolution, and we we can spot the evolution if we look at the early reflection holograms from Denny Juke right through to you know uh the stuff that I've already mentioned, Mike Luke's producing now.
And um, you know, it it's only a time before it starts to uh infiltrate into e everyday life in a way we couldn't possibly uh imagine twenty years ago.
So digital holography is you know certainly uh exciting.
But you do feel that the digital aspect of this is probably going to give it the biggest boost that anything in the past has managed to do, also the full color as well.
Um I think it's inevitable, Frank.
Um if we if we consider a moment, you know, uh one of the major factors of the successful holographic image is measurement.
Being precise about the way we do things, from you know, light meter reading through to calibration of materials and so on and so forth.
Mm-hmm.
The one big advantage the digital media now offers us is that we can be more precise and more accurate beyond anything we could have done using anal analog technology before.
Okay.
So um and also you see what what happens is opens up new um possibilities into the application of holographic technology to the broader area of for example architecture.
Uh certainly as we've seen in security and and you know, development of rice there at the moment.
Engineering as well.
Engineering.
So there will be this sort of um resurrection of holography, okay.
You know, as Steve Benson said, but basically finding a new solution to to old problems, but then maybe, you know, good science is about that.
Do you think it will cut the value of the artistic work that has been produced so far by hand?
Do you think that will be just as much appreciated in the future?
Because obviously working by hand we cannot produce what can be done digitally.
Right.
And will that sort of make handmade holography go the way of uh handmade cabinets?
Uh I don't know.
I'm not sure either.
I don't I mean for things like the the projects that you and I are involved in with the students, you know, hands on holography, you really can't beat sort of understanding optics and what light is from the experience of having a hands on one to one tuition with things.
And recording um a very small scale Denishue hologram of coins, you know, with a diode laser uh with with a a bunch of students is always gonna be a magical experience.
Yes.
You know, given given that they're the first time in their lives of a truly asking, you know, substantial questions about photonics and, you know, how a lens works and what is what is uh what is light?
What is light?
Yes.
What what's light?
What's the k what's going on with the chemical track?
I mean, I have students coming into my lab who just can't believe um how much they've learned at the end of the day from making a very simple Denisuk hologram.
Yeah.
So for me I suppose, you know um it's not an irrelevant question and because there all there always be this sort of appreciation for the the handmade holograms that we've seen from people from you know Peter Miller through to Mike Burridge and Nick Phillips's holograms with holog holoco and there's always going to be a collector's uh sort of niche for that.
And I think it is relevant that um times have changed.
Yes.
I know.
I I I fear that I may be um reaching the end of uh my involvement with the progress of holography because I I sort of draw the line at automation and th I I I like holography the same way that you go to someone who builds cabinets or builds handmade tables or chairs.
I don't know maybe you're more into the zenophilography.
You know the peace you get when you when you're in a lab alone and you're just staring at the the spread beam on the wall and you know the the the stable environment the the whole sort of peace that you get from from being in that situation.
Peace is a very good word.
And I guess y you you don't have that.
You can't you don't afford those luxuries with digital holography which tends to be a an automated process.
Yes.
So this Dmontford University am I pronouncing that correctly?
Uh D Mont D Montford De Montford University.
This name has been involved with holography for many many years, hasn't it?
Yes it is this institution.
Um well originally it was uh formed the uh Department of Modern Optics was formed by Professor Mig Phillips uh which would have been I guess uh in the early eighties and uh Nick as you know was responsible for much of the important work with the early processing regimes uh from Anglo through to Rilford and more recently with uh DuPont um and it's always been relatively high profile in its in its science base.
And uh fairly recently Nick's team moved to uh a new lab in Wales called Optic Technium and uh Nick uh was uh fortunate to team up with Hans Bellehagen uh who's again a pioneer of colour holograms, I'm sure you know how um and uh I I happened to be around at the time.
I'd been working um in the holographic image studio in central London for twenty years and I've I'd reached the point where I felt that you know most of my commercial energies were being had been spent on coming up sort of you know uh my uh late forties and it was time for me to perhaps have a more serious dab at some of the more what I felt were the more important issues, um questions I was asking about holography.
Mm-hmm.
And I was offered a job at De Montfort as a senior research fellow which um I jumped at immediately fell in love with the idea of spending all my time teaching and developing uh IP and was uh successful in being awarded a chair at De Montfort um just last year.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
So I'm now the professor of modern holography at DeMontford University.
That's a great title.
Yeah.
I'm not quite sure what it means.
Maybe that's the idea.
And we're honored to have you on the program.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, it's an honor to uh to to be interviewed by you.
Is this the same location?
Now I'm just going by memory on this.
Is this the same location where the uh upcoming conference in September holography in the modern museum is going to be held?
Yes, it is.
Yes, okay.
So that's the connection there that I that I caught on that.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's the obsession with three dimensional imaging anyway?
Why do we absolutely have to have a medium that's three dimensional?
Isn't what we have with our high resolution, high definition televisions enough?
You can trace it back through the history of art right through to, you know uh the invention of perspective um in the Italian Renaissance.
Um it's something to do with the representation of reality.
And um my my theory, my take on this this whole thing at the moment, is um today we live in such a a fast paced, you know, fast moving world that we actually find security in things we know are fakes.
Huh.
Did you say the word fakes?
F A K E S.
Yeah.
Huh if we can identify something like a hologram as being a representation of the real world.
Okay.
And we know that to be a fake, we find we find a certain amount of rein re reassurance in that because if we know w if we know what a fake is we can then begin to define what reality is.
Oh isn't that interesting?
So I think that's that's my my take on why we're we're becoming so obsessed currently you know with with um three dimensional imaging again.
And of course everything that's three dimensional today is called a hologram, which probably drives you nuts as much as it drives me nuts.
So it it happened to me this morning actually Frank somebody sent me a link to an animated hologram website and of course it turns out to be the old Peppers ghost repackaged.
Oh, I see, yeah.
And uh yeah, what can we do about that?
I don't know.
I wouldn't even go into some of the emails that I get from the general public all the time on stuff, you know.
Yeah.
That's the the most bizarre stuff.
Really?
I finally put on my email page that if you see three-dimensional images at night in your bedroom floating around the room, please contact your doctor, not me.
I want to be nasty to people, but you know, that's that's another realm that you're talking about.
It's not holography.
That's that's uh that's a that's a physician's uh problem there with medication, I'm sure.
Now you did a uh 3D conference and you have a PowerPoint and an MP3 file at your website.
I do that folks can download.
Yeah.
Is your book also available at Amazon.com?
Uh no, but if uh if anyone is interested in receiving a copy, if they uh log on to my website and send me an email with their details.
I've got about I guess I've got about a hundred a hundred copies I would be able to send for uh three.
For free, you said?
Yeah, for three.
Well, let me let me I was gonna buy me up on that.
I was gonna buy one, so let me get on that list.
If it was at Amazon, I was gonna go over and order it actually.
So let me get on that list.
Okay and uh we'll see who else uh contacts you.
We'll find out who really listens to this show or not.
Exactly.
That's gonna be interesting, isn't it?
Uh anything else you'd like to add since we're coming up on twenty five minutes and there's really only so much, and there's such a varied audience that's listening to this as well.
Which is why I try and give a little sample of uh of just about everything that can be covered rather than sticking on one specific type of topic.
Okay.
Anything that you would like the listeners to know about or to hear about?
I'll tell you what would be interesting, Frank, is um you mentioned earlier some of the you know, famous people I've worked with in the past and the list is long, as you know, and you know the list includes people like the film director Martin School Zate, um I've got a series of post holograms with him, the painter Peter Blake, uh the British father of what we refer to as the pop pop art uh Alan Parker, the David Bowie images.
Now all of these holograms, all of these masters are being stored in some silver trunks in my lab.
You know, and I'm keeping them there for posterity.
But the key question is what happens to these things when I'm no longer around?
So what I'd like to to hear from your listeners is if anyone has a suggestion what I can do with these holograms in the long term, let me know.
If they if honestly, if they can think of a a deserving cause or a museum that we could uh you know, have these holograms donated to, I would be listening.
Well, isn't that something?
Well, let's see what the listeners would say.
I don't think you're going to hear from any of the school students or teachers, but uh or many of the other people who are listening, but they may send something to you.
Uh but some of the holographers out there may contact you on that.
Have you contacted the International Holography Fund or some other I I consider that sort of a a type of governing organization.
Absolutely.
Abs I'm very pleased you mentioned that because I just I just wanted to say how delighted I am that you know something like this has come along and it's a lifeline to uh struggling artists who really need help.
Yeah.
And uh, you know, I I I've much admired uh Posey Jackson's work with the sheerwater and Andy Pepper's hard work in there.
And I can't tell you how how much it's helped people in the past and uh long may it continue into the future.
I agree.
I was actually a recipient of that for the whole talk, which I'm very proud to say.
Fantastic.
Well it you know, good cause there.
Yes, very much.
And it is a tough field.
You know, I mean you're talking about people who have to sometimes truly wonder where they're going to get groceries, you know, to put food on the table.
Yeah.
Well, I've seen it and experienced it actually many times.
It's very up and down like a roller coaster.
It takes its toll on you after a while too.
Yeah.
But here we are.
We're still doing it.
You would think with all the things that we're doing that uh, you know, nothing would be a problem in our lives, you know.
Oh well.
Hey, it was our choice, so you know, here's what we got.
So let's think we wouldn't have it any other way.
I don't think it could be any other way.
I look back at a lifetime of this, I don't know what what it could have been.
Well, Martin, I want to thank you very much.
I know everyone's gonna enjoy listening to your uh interview and it will be archived over at the Profiles and Holography website.
And uh I guess I should probably try and keep these interviews a little bit more art based, considering it's uh, you know, art and holography type of uh format for this uh profiles and holography.
But it's also good to get to know the artist a little bit as well, which I think we've accomplished here today, learning a little about you.
Thank you very much.
I hope we get a chance to meet someday.
I'm sure we will.
And I look forward to the day when uh when all of you come over here to the States and I can meet you here, because I uh I don't fly, and that's uh that's another one of my drawbacks to actually accomplishing anything in this field is not getting on a plane.
That's a shame.
Yeah, it is, yeah.
Especially, you know, when you have to drive everywhere and the it's like eighteen hours to get somewhere.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Have a good rest of the day.
Thank you.
And uh a good weekend, and thank you for coming on the show.
Live long and prosper.
Yes, sir.
Goodbye.
Cheers now.